hey everybody dr. Mike here everyone has
their morning routine and I like to show
you what mine is like to prepare me for
a hectic day in the hospital the first
thing I like to do in the morning when I
open my eyes is to grab a glass of warm
lemon water the warm water allows your
digestive system to improve its
circulation and get ready to start the
day
also lemons contain two great nutrients
potassium and a little bit of vitamin C
which is great especially if the night
before you had a great workout or maybe
even had an extra drink of alcohol that
you should have had
[Music]
the second thing I like to do when I
wake up in the mornings is to make my
bed it sounds like a small task but your
brain loves achieving goals big or small
and setting a small goal that's easily
achievable allows your brain to set
bigger goals throughout the day most
importantly who doesn't like coming home
to a clean bed us come on you're late
with the five a great trick to waking up
in the morning that's even better than
caffeine a superior cold shower but you
don't need to take the full cold shower
adjuster with warm anubhav and do 10
seconds of cold just like this science
says it can even improve the Sasori
circulation
[Music]
got to get dressed that's a no-brainer
everyone's doing it sometimes I'll need
to wear scrubs if I'm working in the
emergency room or the obstetric
department sometimes I'll need to put on
a suit if I'm doing a formal
presentation or seeing patients inside
my clinic I like my scrubs to be very
fitted a lot about being a doctor is
about your nonverbal cues how you
present yourself I also like my scrubs
to be bright colored happy and really
show that confident energy that I like
to give to my patients every single day
another crucial part of my morning
routine is an easy five-minute warm-up
I'm not telling you to do a full
exercise regimen when you wake up but
take a few minutes move your body around
they'll do wonders for your
concentration your flexibility and most
importantly will prevent injury my
favorite part of the morning is taking
this little husky out for a walk
Roxy obviously needs her daily morning
exercise but it's also a great time for
me to do some self-reflection leave my
cell phone behind enjoy the beauty of
the city maybe get a little vitamin D if
it's sunny out but ultimately I find out
walk is a great way for me to meditate
and get ready for the rest of my day
last but not least got to get some food
in me before I head out to the hospital
proteins complex carbohydrates great
ways to start your day get some eggs
whole wheat bread maybe some oatmeal
leave you feeling full and energized
throughout your entire workday I also
like to grab a quick snack like a banana
get some vitamins in because the
hospital can be a crazy place you need a
quick snack so I'm ready to start my day
if you do something interesting in your
morning routine that you like to share
with me leave it in the comments there's
something you like to know more about
your morning routine leave it in the
comments and if you haven't hit and
subscribe already hit that button now
[Music]